ahora quiero presentarles una nueva idea
que es la de tener voltaje o corriente
una señal eléctrica como función del
tiempo coseno de omega t aquí lo que
hacemos es presentar el tiempo como
argumento de una función coseno y el
tiempo es algo que siempre va a aumentar
es un número que se incrementa por
siempre y aquí tenemos otra variable que
se llama omega es la letra minúscula
griega o mega y aquí omega tiene un
trabajo importante el argumento de un
coseno cualquier cosa que tengamos aquí
adentro debe ser a dimensional es decir
no debe tener unidades así que aquí sí
tenemos una unidad de segundos
significa que omega debe ser algo que
tiene unidades 1 entre segundo o 1 sobre
tiempo así que omega es 1 sobre tiempo y
al multiplicar estos dos números vamos a
tener algo que no tiene unidades y
después podemos obtener su coseno y con
esto nos referimos a la frecuencia algo
que tiene unidades de 1 sobre tiempo es
una
frecuencia este es un número constante y
t es un número que aumenta todo el
tiempo así que cuando obtenemos el
coseno de esto vamos a tener una onda
coseno u onda senoidal y esta onda va a
formarse conforme aumenta el tiempo va a
continuar por siempre
ahora transformamos nuestra función
trigonométricas coseno que es esto de
aquí algo que está bien definido entre 0
y 2 y radiales
no tengo que aquí cambiamos el eje aquí
ahora tenemos el tiempo por lo que
tendremos este eje ahora en segundos dos
segundos 3 45 segundos y este punto de
aquí es pi segundos aquí tenemos dos
segundos y podemos ver que aquí tenemos
un ciclo completo de mi onda coseno
antes de que vuelva a repetirse
aquí tenemos 6.28 segundos y para esta
imagen de aquí o mega tiene el valor de
1 por lo que cuando te el tiempo alcanza
los 2 segundos habremos recorrido un
ciclo completo así que esta idea de este
coseno que está cambiando continuamente
su onda seno que está cambiando
continuamente nos da el término de onda
senoidal es y las ondas senoidal es son
un buen modelo de muchas cosas que
ocurren en la naturaleza si escuchamos
un tono
o una nota pura de una campana o un
silbato o si cantan una nota las formas
de estos tonos lucirán como ondas xenón
world as coseno y estas cosas a menudo
se encuentran en nuestros circuitos
electrónicos y vamos a querer hacer
cosas con ellas ahora quiero hablar un
poco más acerca de los detalles de esta
onda senoidal vamos a aprender nuevos
términos relacionados con esto una idea
importante es la idea de cualquier forma
que se repite o señal que se repite es
la idea de periodo veamos este punto que
atraviesa el cero aquí si tomo el cambio
de tiempo de aquí a acá si veo el cambio
en el tiempo de aquí a acá este es un
intervalo que se repite de esta función
y a esta distancia de acá le vamos a
llamar el periodo el periodo de esta
función senoidal que de hecho esta onda
es una onda coseno y el periodo de este
coche no es esta distancia de aquí y el
símbolo que usamos para representar esto
típicamente es la letra mayúscula t con
esto indicamos el periodo
ahora veamos esta onda coseno esta onda
senoidal vamos a identificar cuál es su
periodo y puedo hacerlo fácilmente si me
fijo en esta parte de aquí pues parece
que de aquí a acá tenemos una repetición
cada vez que llegamos a uno de estos
puntos tendremos una repetición si este
es el tiempo cero aquí este es el tiempo
de mayúscula y este será el tiempo dos
de mayúscula y si me fijo en el valor en
esta gráfica vemos que el tiempo es de
punto cero dos segundos por lo que te es
igual a cero punto 0 2 segundos y es así
como encontramos el periodo de cualquier
onda senoidal podemos tomar otros puntos
por ejemplo este punto de aquí y a
partir de ahí recorremos un ciclo
completo y llegamos acá y este será
nuestro periodo t y tendrá el mismo
valor que esta t de acá así que a este
tiempo t también le podemos llamar ciclo
un ciclo es el tiempo que les lleva a
recorrer todo un periodo así que a este
tiempo le podemos llamar también ciclo
es el tiempo que tardamos en recorrer
todo un periodo así que una pregunta que
puedo hacerles con respecto a esta onda
senoidal es cuántos ciclos caben en un
segundo otra forma de decirlo es cuántos
ciclos tiene por segundo podemos decir
que un ciclo ocurre cada
de segundos y en nuestro caso particular
tenemos un ciclo cada punto 0 2 segundos
y si tomamos el recíproco de punto 0 2
nos queda que la respuesta es 50 ciclos
por segundo
esta es la rapidez la tasa de repetición
de esta senoidal 50 ciclos por segundo y
esto tiene otro nombre otro nombre que
es en honor a un científico alemán
apellidado hertz esto es un hertz
heinrich hertz fue la primera persona en
enviar una onda de radio y recibirla a
propósito y sabía lo que estaba haciendo
y llamamos a la unidad ciclos por
segundo en su honor ahora tenemos dos
formas de medir la frecuencia una es efe
que es la frecuencia que se mide en
hertz y son ciclos por segundo un ciclo
es igual a dos pi radiales por segundo
así que las dos medidas son ciclos por
segundo o radiales por segundo y vamos a
pasar de una a otra para radiales por
segundo la variable es omega y a esto le
llamamos frecuencia angular
o frecuencia en radiales a veces vemos
la palabra rap que se usa para indicar
qué es la frecuencia angular o
frecuencia en radiales y la variable es
omega veamos cuál es la relación entre f
y omega
de hecho la tenemos aquí si nos dan una
f
a que será igual omega
tengo un número f que está en ciclos por
segundo y esto lo voy a multiplicar por
un factor de conversión que ahorita
vamos a ver va a ser dos radiales por
segundo que es lo mismo que un ciclo por
segundo y esto es igual ciclos por
segundo se cancelan con ciclos por
segundo lo que nos da dos pi por efe
radiales por segundo
así que el factor de conversión es omega
igual a 2 pi por efe esto vale la pena
recordarlo
si tengo por ejemplo una onda senoidal
de voltaje vedete igual a coseno de
omega te puedo escribir esto también
como ddt coseno de dos tipos
efe por t
una de las frecuencias está en ciclos
por segundo y esta otra está en radiales
por segundo y podemos intercambiarlas de
esta forma usando este factor de
conversión si tomamos el ejemplo que
vimos al principio del vídeo teníamos
una señal que tenía un ciclo de 50 hertz
50 ciclos por segundo
aquí la escribimos así vedete igual a
coseno de 2 pi efe y aquí
efe es 50 por t y esto es lo mismo que
el coseno de 100 pi porte y este número
de aquí 100 pi es omega y este número de
aquí es efe y hasta aquí llega nuestra
revisión de trigonometría donde
presentamos la idea de una onda senoidal
en donde t es el argumento de la función
trigonométricas